[Musique]
ce sont les enfants les moins bien logés
qui sont les premiers rentrée l'école
1h15 pour eux la cour de récréation est
un monde privilégié où l'on peut enfin
s'ébattre à son aise là on a de la place
pour jouer et pour se détendre
j'aime beaucoup cette heure-là et que la
salle à manger et balayer chez nous je
descends dans la cour pour jouer au
volley ball avec le grand c'est le seul
moment de la journée où professeurs et
élèves s'affrontent sur un pied
d'égalité pour mes filles leur joie à ce
moment là c'est d'aller rendre visite à
l'école maternelle mes cinq enfants ils
sont passés à tour de rôle entre deux
ans et demi et cinq ans aujourd'hui
bernadette et claire sont en cours
élémentaire catherine et marie christine
en cours moyen première année et marie
madeleine en cours moyen 2e année une
heure et demie le silence revient dans
l'école
pour les petits de la maternelle c'est
la séance laborieuse de lavage des mains
qui de cabinet
dans la cour chaque fils d'élèves se met
en branle religieusement
c'est une sorte de rite immuable et les
clashs reprennent
[Musique]